[Musique]
vous diriez que tucked était pourtant l'une
des communautés les plus touchées par le
changement climatique dans tout le Canada, c'est juste dans
votre visage, on nous dit que la
communauté de Tuck elle-même d'ici 50 à 80
ans n'existera plus
nous  pourrait se heurter à une catastrophe
où la communauté se trouve là où se trouve l'
hôpital dans un certain nombre de maisons sera
perdue dans la mer elle disparaît
si vous vivez avec la transformation perpétuelle
alors ce qui se passe avec le
changement climatique n'est pas si radicalement différent à
nouveau c'est juste juste des souvenirs
nous  je ne vois plus
qu'on veut rester ici je ne vivrais jamais
ailleurs
[Musique]